[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition spéciale sur tv
60,18 bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
pour cette émission du vendredi 10 avril
le coc u19 qui continue de faire des
victimes dans le département 16 morts
supplémentaires ont été recensés hier ce
qui porte à 235 le nombre de décès mais
c'est une première depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire
il y a moins de patients hospitalisés
est en réanimation aux derniers chiffres
de santé publique france 1035 personnes
étaient hospitalisées hier soit 5 de
moins par rapport à mercredi
186 patient était en réanimation cette
demande en 24 heures le nombre de
sorties suite à une amélioration de
l'état de santé est lui toujours en
hausse 647 retour à domicile ont été
enregistrés à ce jour pour répondre aux
besoins des hôpitaux justement est aussi
à répondre à la demande du gouvernement
un consortium s'est créé fin mars
il est constitué autour de quatre
industriels français réunissant air
liquide psa schneider electrics et valeo
l'objectif produire et 10000 respirateur
en 50 jours une véritable prouesse alors
qu'en temps normal air liquide ne
produit que 200 appareils de ce type par
an pour l'équipementier automobile valeo
dont l'un des sites en france est
implanté à la verrière il s'agit de
mettre à profit ses compétences
spécifiques dans les systèmes thermiques
mais pas uniquement
écoutez à ce propos françois board il
est l'un des responsables du site saint
quentinois de valeo yoplait dont on le
coiffeur consortium avec notre
expérience en achats approvisionnements
en r&d entre recherche et développement
tout ce qui est électronique ou
mécanique et en production systèmes de
production au total valeo il ya une
vingtaine de personnes qui supportent ce
consortium
dans cette première phase d'étude et
d'approvisionnement et on va commenter
cette semaine faire de la production
d'appareils d'augmenter la production
et là on a fait appel au volontariat
pour elle et sur le site d'air liquide
produire des appareils montée des
appareils et on est en train de faire un
appel aux volontaires
rien ça va démarrer cette semaine ce
week-end pour la partie mon potager
formation est identique chez les autres
partenaires les trois partenaires que
sont edf à schneider et valeo c'est
d'abord une grande fierté pour tous les
membres valeo de participer à cette
aventure est pour moi une bonne surprise
de voir combien sont motivés tous les
gens qui touchent de près ou de loin ce
projet et qu'ils veulent ou qu'ils
proposent d'apporter leur aide leur
support et de façon très dynamique et
très réactif est l'un des débats du
moment en france faut-il ou non porter
un masque lorsque l'on est non soignants
l'académie de médecine a affirmé la
semaine dernière qu'un modèle grand
public devrait être élargi et rendu
obligatoire pour les sorties et pour le
déconfinement de nombreuses initiatives
ont donc été initiée à coignières la
municipalité a lancé un appel à la
mobilisation pour la confection de
masques un tissu 14 couturier en herbe
ont répondu à ce jour pour rejoindre
l'élan il suffit de se faire connaître
par mail en laissant nom prénom adresse
et numéro de téléphone est la commune
réceptionnera les masses qui en
organisera la distribution auprès des
citoyens 500 seront remises dans un
premier temps aux personnes les plus
vulnérables
les précisions du maire de coignières
joint par téléphone la population nous a
posé la question nous a dit tout
simplement
oui mais nous aussi on a besoin de
masque on n'en trouve pas dans les
pharmacies on ne peut pas en trouver on
ne nous en vend pas donc c'est là que je
me suis dit finalement il ya peut-être
une solution qui serait de faire un
appel citoyen à la population pour
confectionner en fait c'est masquer la
commune fournit la matière première
c'est à dire le tissu et les élastiques
les gens s'inscrivent parce qu'on les
reçoit sur rendez vous pour venir
chercher
finalement cette matière première et
puis ensuite fabrique chez eux donc les
masques et nous renvoie ensuite ces
masques fabriqués et à charge pour nous
pour la commune
de les répartir et pour tout complément
d'information vous pouvez joindre le
cabinet du maire de coignières par
téléphone via le numéro qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
24e jour de confinement en france avec
de nombreux commerces qui ont dû baisser
le rideau temporairement comme le panier
de la ferme à et que vit la boutique
continue tout de même son activité en
proposant du driver des livraisons de
fruits et légumes son producteur a dû
faire appel à des bénévoles pour gérer
l'afflux de commandes et la protection
civile des yvelines est venu lui prêter
main forte le reportage de mathilde et
demi et de patrick jacques de dixmude au
panier de la ferme
parmi les petites mains qui s'affairent
pour s'occuper des commandes on trouve
les bénévoles de la protection civile
des yvelines nouvelle mission pour ces
volontaires préparation de cageots et de
paniers pour les clients mais sans
contact physique
nous avons déjà des bénévoles qui
commandait par internet au ca auprès de
cette ferme est donc suite à cette crise
ou bien dans la discussion dans la
communication n'a su qu'ils seraient
énormément difficulté puisqu'ils ont par
rapport aux chiffres quotidiens qu'ils
ont habituellement ils ont plus de 400
personnes qui commandent actuellement
par internet
donc ils se sont complètement senti
débordé donc ils ont demandé si avec nos
missions s'il était possible qu'on
vienne les renforcer des renforts
précieux pour les paniers de la ferme
le gérant a organisé des espaces pour
accueillir tous les bénévoles en évitant
un maximum les contacts ça va bien
soulagé surtout dans le sens où gronde
déjà
nous on voulait pas parce que j'ai eu
des demandes aussi bénévoles etc
le problème c'est qu'en ce moment on
essaie quand même même si on reçoit
beaucoup de public
on essaie de se confiner de se protéger
nous aussi donc on a une équipe qui nous
on va dire confiné même si j'ai des
salariés mais on est confiné entre loups
et après l'après midi j'ai mais plutôt
justement c'est comme j'ai l'avantagé
aussi d'avoir plusieurs bâtiments
ils sont dans un bâtiment de leur côté
et nous on est de notre côté et ça
permet d'éviter aussi trop les contacter
isabelle est venu prêter main forte à la
ferme pour la préparation des commandes
mais aussi pour les livraisons de
paniers aux personnes âgées
elle fait elle aussi partie de la
protection civile des yvelines
j'ai été malade j'ai protégé ma famille
je ne souhaite pas d'eau feront
directement du convive 19
donc ça me permet de faire une mission
utile mais en protéger quoi la plupart
des commandes sont à récupérer à des
horaires précis du mercredi au samedi à
la ferme de la muette à ecquevilly les
autres colis seront livrés à domicile
pour les personnes à risque et nous
sommes à présent avec le président de la
protection civile des yvelines arnaud
cette valve bonsoir bonsoir
alors on vient de voir cette action de
soutien pour cet agriculteur dès que vie
mais la protection civile des yvelines
est aussi en renfort du samu notamment
vous êtes mobilisés en fait sur
plusieurs fronts pendant cette crise
sanitaire exactement habituellement on
fait les gars nous auprès des
sapeurs-pompiers les yvelines
précisément sur un centre de secours de
versailles et dans cette crise sans
précédent pour la france on a décidé
conjointement avec les sapeurs-pompiers
de mettre à disposition des équipes du
samu une équipe de jour comme de nuit
qui se relève comme plusieurs plusieurs
fois en france puisque en france et à
peu près 150 ambulance et la protection
civile en fait partie vous êtes aussi
mobilisés dans les hôpitaux vous avez
des bénévoles qui sont directement dans
ses hôpitaux pour orienter informer les
personnes qui se rendent dans ces
hôpitaux exactement on a contractualisé
avec le groupement hospitalier
territorial a qui s occupe des hôpitaux
de plusieurs hôpitaux du nord du
département et on a des missions très
spécifique sur l'hôpital de poissy sur
l'hôpital de mantes la jolie
l'action elle est douce et à la fois de
pouvoir accueillir et orienter les
personnes soit qui se rendent aux
urgences avec le dispositif au sein des
postes médicaux métier fait un bide et
poste médicalisé et ensuite on a toute
une grande partie
sur autre chose par exemple sur
l'accueil très simplement dans à
l'accueil principalement de delta pour
pouvoir aller pour orienter les
personnes sur sur différentes choses et
on parlait des bénévoles la protection
civile fonctionne aussi grâce à ses
bénévoles se sont combien de bénévoles
qui sont en ce moment au mobilisées dans
le département des yvelines
alors on a une quarantaine de bénévoles
et on a également activé une réserve
départementale de protection civile qui
est compétente et de 60 bénévoles
supplémentaires le temps de la crise
donc on est sur un potentiel sur les
yvelines 2 115 bénévoles consultables
sur sûr aussi bien sous les tâches
administratives mais également sur des
missions bien plus précise et vous êtes
appuyé sur votre socle de bénévoles déjà
existants ou est ce qu'il ya de nouveaux
bénévoles qui se sont fait connaître
aussi pour apporter leur pierre à
l'édifice en sept ans cette crise on a
eu énormément de demandes spontanées je
remercie aussi les personnes qui ont pu
le faire aussi bien à travers notre
national le site départemental et les
sites du gouvernement
il ya beaucoup de personnes aussi bien à
domicile sur des missions et qui sont
quand vous avez pu le voir aussi avec
l'agriculteur 2d des missions
logistiques donc on a on a besoin de
personne et ces personnes ne sont pas ne
sont pas inutiles dans notre
organisation et c'est très important
pour pouvoir protéger le minimum comment
vous êtes vous adapté pour mener à bien
justement ces actions est aussi
peut-être protéger vos bénévoles qui
sont sur le terrain comment vous êtes
vous organisé alors sur la protection
déjà on a sollicité nos différents
partenaires par exemple pour avoir une
protection à un sas de protection à
l'intérieur de notre ambulance qui nous
permet de pouvoir à la fois protéger la
victime et protéger l'ensemble de nos
équipes
on remercie également nos partenaires
comme le samu qui nous met à disposition
des équipements de première de fin des
équipements de protection individuelle
plutôt et tout
tous ces équipements en fait concourent
à la sécurité de nos bénévoles mais
également des réservistes puisque même
s'ils sont les ervices pour nous ils
font partie intégrante de la protection
civile et on doit faire également
attention à eux est quelque chose
d'important on développe aussi des
techniques comme on a pu le voir par
exemple tout au long de l'année on donne
des cours de technique d'optimisation du
potentiel et techniques militaires de
stratégies mentales pour gérer le stress
la fatigue et les émotions et on leur
permet aussi gratuitement de pouvoir
continuer à se sensibiliser comme ça
parce que pour nous c'est très sain
en y puisse durer maintenant mais aussi
après tout en gérant cet aspect fatick
qui qui est très très important et
primordial pour une dernière question on
a constaté que le nombre
d'hospitalisations et de réanimation est
en légère baisse dans le département
qu'avez-vous envie de dire aux yvelinois
qui peut être voit que les beaux jours
reviennent qui se disent peut-être la
crise est derrière est passé qu'est ce
que vous avez envie de leur dire aux
yvelinois 20,2 de continuer à rester
chez eux
on sait que c'est compliqué de continuer
à suivre les recommandations de la
préfecture du gouvernement de respecter
parce que c'est eux qui savent ce qu'il
faut faire et même nous mêmes les
bénévoles qui n'ont pas de missions
liées à la protection civile à un
instant t il reste à leur domicile la
preuve pour pour moi qui reste confinée
moi-même pour pouvoir continuer à gérer
mes équipes au quotidien donc restons
sérieux faisons tous et restons tous
citoyens
merci arnaud théval et je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de la protection
civile des yvelines on parlait
agriculture tout à l'heure restons dans
cette thématique mais à présent à saint
cyr l'école en raison des mesures
sanitaires les fermes de gally font
évoluer leur mode de fonctionnement
l'enseigne laisse ouvert le marché et
l'épicerie et mais la cueillette est
suspendu il est néanmoins possible de
venir récupérer et des paniers de
légumes en passant commande les
explications avec ce sujet de wilfrid
richier de patrick jacques de dixmude
j'aime beaucoup la cueillette et on est
un petit peu privé l'a pas pouvoir aller
cueillir soi-même mais bon voilà je
trouve que c'est une très belle idée
d'avoir mis ça en place plus de
cueillette dans les champs afin d'éviter
tout contact entre les clients mais pour
autant il reste donc possible de
s'approvisionner en fruits et légumes
auprès des fermes de gally ce qu'on a
proposé c'est la première fois qu'on le
fait c'est de réaliser des des cagettes
de légumes frais puisqu'ils ont été
accueillis ce matin ils ont été mis dans
les cages est là cette fin de matinée et
on l'est on les distribue le jeudi
après-midi pour l'unss entre 15h et 17h
un vrai attrait parce que beaucoup de
gens ont du mal à trouver des légumes
frais ils recherchent des légumes en
circuit court donc c
est-ce qu'on pratique nous depuis plus
de 30 ans à la cueillette de gally
épinards blade salade et même tulipes
pour passer les commandes il faut se
rendre sur le site de l'établissement et
payer en ligne au point de contact est
très très rapide on a le nom la liste
des gens qui ont réglé leur leurs
cagettes
ils viennent sur un créneau de deux
trois heures ils donnent leur nom on
vérifie on rails ils partent avec
l'europe malgré tout la diminution de
l'activité est notable et autres
difficultés que rencontre cette
entreprise agricole
la poursuite également des plantations
pour les autres saisons courgettes
aubergines ou encore tomates pour
s'assurer de la bonne continuité du
travail certains postes ont ainsi été
modifié une entreprise qui est assez
diversifié donc il ya des branches de
l'entreprise
ils sont très touchées est d'ailleurs
une partie de ses salariés qui n'avaient
plus de travail du fait de la
conjoncture sont embauchés et viennent
travailler en entraide sur d'autres
activités
l'activité agricole ne peut pas
s'arrêter sédiments si on arrête tout on
savait difficile de manger adaptation
également du côté des transports avec
forcément moins de voyageurs le réseau
stibus par exemple a connu une baisse de
fréquentation de 90% cette période de
confinement et des mesures sanitaires
ont été prises par saint quentin en
yvelines et ile-de-france mobilité
montée des passagers par l'arrière et
désinfection systématique des cabines
par les chauffeurs après leur service et
des ajustements également sur le trafic
des bus avec quatre cinquième des
effectifs mobilisés et ce jusqu'à la fin
du confinement écouté le directeur des
mobilités de saint quentin en yvelines
nous avons déployé l'offre du samedi
était donc de l'offre qui habituellement
fin juillet ou début août
donc c'est à peu près un quart de
l'offre habituelle qui est présente sur
le secteur
alors on a fait des petits ajustements
ponctuels pour certaines entreprises
notamment on l'a juste est pour avec la
ligne 50 pour atos oakley on l'a fait
aussi pour safran avec la 39 12 et puis
bien évidemment on a mis une offre qui
est plutôt l'offre de la semaine en été
pour les hôpitaux et notamment pour les
lignes qui desservent donc l'hôpital
privé de trappes mais aussi pour aller
aux chaînés et même la ligne qui va à
l'hôpital de clamart donc pour
les établissements médicaux on a une
offre correspond à la semaine donc la
semaine l'été un économie avec un point
à présent sur le secteur bancaire
comment les établissements réagi style
pour accompagner professionnels et
particuliers exemple avec le crédit
agricole nicolas landry a interrogé la
directrice régionale
[Musique]
je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui 100% de
nos agences sont ouvertes dans les
yvelines
alors on est ouverts certes mais on
travaille différemment avec des agences
qui sont ouvertes au niveau du libre
service bancaire c'est l'endroit où vous
pouvez faire vos opérations sur les
automates le libre service bancaire
ouvert le matin aux horaires habituels
de lagence et toute la journée
les conseillers sont joignables à
distance par leurs clients donc on
continue à travailler et être à l'écouté
de nos clients mais différemment
[Musique]
deux choses
déjà les pose sur les crédits ça dès
qu'on organise des pauses sur sur les
crédits là on en a fait je regardais sur
notre direction régionale depuis le
début de la crise 1371 pause et puis
maintenant la grande actualité c'est le
prêt garanti par l'état le prêt auquel
ont droit des entreprises jusqu'à 25 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires 2010 9
c'est la grosse activité du moment tous
nos conseillers sont sur le pont des
clients examine leurs besoins et on est
en cours d'instruction et déjà les
premiers dossiers ont été réalisés
[Musique]
et crédits à l'habitat sont un peu à
l'arrêt en ce moment les nos beaux
projets sont plutôt à l'arrêt mais il
nous reste tous les anciens projets qui
était qui on avait commencé à instruire
avant crise et qu'on finalise avec les
clients naturellement parce que on a la
chance d'avoir encore nos services de
back office qui sont complètement
opérationnels et qui peuvent assurer la
réalisation des opérations jusqu'au bout
on a aussi pas mal de préoccupation de
particulier sur les marchés financiers
qui sont particulièrement agitée en ce
moment la bourse alors beaucoup de
questions est ce que c'est le moment
d'acheter
est-ce que c'est trop tôt est ce que
c'est trop tard comment y aller
et donc là on est très très sollicité un
conseil sur sur ces sujets là il faut
reconnaître que les pouvoirs publics
avaient agisse avec détermination pour
maintenir la confiance à on a vu il ya
beaucoup de mesures pour les petites en
place
le chômage partiel l'aller mais report
d'impôt de charges sociales les différer
de crédit des banques
les prêts donc tout ça devrait être de
nature à limiter l'impact financier même
si on aura de toute façon la question
qui pourrait se poser c'est est ce que
les banques sont solides pour assurer
aussi cette période par rapport à 2008
qui était la dernière crise très très
forte inconnu des banques
la situation est plus du tout la même
dans la mesure où les mesures de
renforcement des fonds propres ont été
très très forte
ça a conduit consomme au dos les banques
à doubler leur niveau de décote par
rapport à cette période là donc elles
sont beaucoup plus solides
actuellement pour accompagner les ce
crise économique et se met au service de
l'économie réelle justement
et j - 2 avant pâques et le personnel
soignant engagés dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus qui pourra profiter de repas
concocté par des chefs et dans le cadre
de l'opération un bon repas pour bien
soigner frédéric l'art comme un chef du
restaurant étoilé du gordon ramsay au
trianon à versailles va préparer 50
repas pour l'hôpital de montreuil en
seine saint denis ils seront livrés
lundi
d'autres chefs se sont joints à
l'initiative lancée par la fondation
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
et puis avant de vous laisser ce soir
retrouvez notre magazine mensuel est
dédiée le 7-8 europe une émission
consacrée forcément à la crise du côté
de 19 vous découvrirez notamment comment
la région et ile de france s'organise
pour redéployer lé fonds européens ou
encore comment des jeunes yvelinois
vivent leur confinement ailleurs en
europe
regardez cet extrait bonjour moi c'est
victoria j'habite actuellement à québec
donc un village situé à une heure de
cardiff la capitale du pays de galles
les centres pour enfants bien évidemment
fermé et étendait que c'est notre
principale mission
on n'avait pas du tout de travail par
ordinateur etc par contre notre créateur
a donc créé un groupe whatsapp sur
lesquelles on peut voir la partager nos
idées on peut chercher ensemble qu'est
ce qu'on peut proposer aux jeunes via la
page facebook de l'association pendant
cette période
voilà ça me permet de rester en contact
et de partager nos idées
elle le sait plutôt représenté par
nicolas kirilow vide c'est ce soir à 20h
sur tv 78 et en replay sur notre site
internet et nos réseaux sociaux voilà
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci de votre fidélité
restez chez vous et très bon week-end
sur tv 78
[Musique]